this thick black smoke could be seen
from miles away as the village of
wennington was engulfed in flame
spreading at a dangerous speed the blaze
ripped through buildings and as locals
were evacuated feelings of shock were
shared
i was scared i was thinking it's going
to get to us and i mean it was very
close
and i was just worried
at one point i was numb i didn't know
what to think i was just all over the
place
and my first thing was get my kids out i
don't even know what to say because i've
never seen i used to see these kind of
fires
on tv i never thought in my in my
wildest dream that would happen to us
the helicopters start coming over
and the more police
are coming into our neighborhood and um
and it was it really spreading very fast
as they process what happened residents
gathered at makeshift refuge centers
like this one i'm not sure what the time
was we won't have lunch and my son come
in and said uh next door's garden's on
fire
so we actually got the hose pipe a
couple of watering canes but after two
or three minutes it was it was clear it
was coming towards the house we don't
know 100 for sure but we have been told
that there is a very high possibility
that our house is
already gone i was actually upstairs at
the time and i actually saw from my
window like the flames really close to
the house so
naturally very very panicked only had a
chance to grab my phone nothing else
following a day which saw temperatures
exceed 40 degrees firefighters fought
numerous places
but what they saw here was unprecedented
we've probably never seen
weather-related incidents particularly
to do with heat on this scale before
but we do have well rehearsed and
practiced plans in place
the full extent of the damage will take
time to determine but we know that
houses schools and churches in the area
have been affected what's driven the
blaze well it's the dry conditions as
well as the hot temperatures which has
meant the situation has been so volatile
as sun said the fire continued to rage
home after home destroyed
this blaze will be a stark reminder of
the dangers extreme heat can bring
aisha zahid sky news